well Ben what did you make of all that
mainstream media madness yesterday well
you know I think the the media are
constantly turning the dial all the way
up to eleven on the spinal tap scale and
that means that it's very difficult for
us to actually determine when something
terribly has gone wrong because
apparently everything is going wrong all
the time and it's it's that scene from
Animal House where Kevin Bacon is
standing in the foreground telling
everybody not to worry as everything's
on fire except the truth is that nothing
is really on fire although the media
would have you believe that everything
is but when you look at the president's
rhetoric you know he has talked talk
tough regarding North Korea a year ago
but that ultimately been resulted in sit
down with a leader of North Korea six
weeks ago now he's talking tough with
the leader of Iran and some is not quite
to the fire and fury level of rhetoric
but nonetheless given the fact that
their economy has imploded the the rial
has dropped by 50 percent over the last
couple of months a run for them it's
time to do something well the President
did unleash caps lock which I believe in
Twitter speak is actually DEFCON 2 so
that means that we all should be on our
on our toes here but again I think the
president is is not one to abide by the
Teddy Roosevelt school of diplomacy that
speaks softly and carry a big stick it's
it's tweet loudly and then do something
and it depends what something is right
so sometimes the something is militant
sometimes it's him flinging a missile
into Syria when when Assad is gassing
children and sometimes it's sitting down
with the person he was ripping on five
seconds ago so the president has always
said that he is very into strategic
unpredictability and and he's been true
to his word on that you're right about
that so the New York governor yesterday
Andrew Cuomo had a press conference and
he announced that he's going to pardon
seven more people who were facing
deportation in December that's right
December he pardoned 18 individuals this
is the third group that he's pardoned
and he said this listen this
administration is on crusade against
people who they do not consider original
Americans what they've done at the
border is an example of it what they've
done in Puerto Rico and they are on a
jihad to the poor
as many people as they can who they
believe are not in the United States
legally Ben what do you think about that
accusing the Trump administration of
waging jihad against illegals first of
all I mean why isn't anyone accusing
Andrew Cuomo of Islamophobia I thought
the jihad only meant internal struggle
so there's that also when when he says
that you know President Trump is is
waging war against illegal immigrants
I'm old enough to remember when the
Obama administration was bragging that
they had increased the number of
deportations now they were lying about
that because what they actually were
doing was just turning more people away
at the border but the fact is that
strictness when it comes to our border
enforcement is actually a pretty popular
policy among most Americans and if
President Trump is attempting to deport
all of the illegal immigrants who are in
the country right now if he's actually
waging war against them he's doing a
pretty poor job of it considering that
11 million legal immigrants are still
living in the country good point Andrew
Cuomo rules the halls of Albany speaking
of Albany State University of New York
at Albany this is gonna be right up your
sleeve because obviously you're a big
speaker on college campuses
last year 64 speakers identified as
liberal only too conservative again the
entire academic year so 2 out of a total
of 66
what say you well it's an echo chamber
and all of these universities have
basically become echo chambers where
because everybody lives in this ivory
tower where all they do is talk with
people who agree with them they start to
believe their own opinions their facts
so what they will tell you is the reason
there are no conservatives on campus is
because conservatives just don't speak
the truth well once you start believing
that your opinion is the truth it makes
it very difficult to hear any other
opinion well clearly they're not
inviting conservatives Ben because
you're so scary I'm you are scary Ben no
I'm sober wildered by all of this I mean
I've been told by everyone that I'm so
scary and my wife doesn't think I'm not
scary but where does this come from is
it is it the times that these professors
grew up that now that they're in charge
and they're they're talking to students
about this that they have convinced
everybody guys like you are scarier
where does that narrative come from we
should not have conservatives speaking
on campus or is it just that they take a
poll that they'd said well we voted and
you know nobody wanted to hear you
I do think that it's an ideological
blind spot I think that a lot of people
on campus believe that their opinion is
the truth and so when it comes to things
for example like tax policy they think
that Keynesianism has been proved and
therefore anybody who disagrees with
that is actually speaking untruth to the
students that they're their bubble of
truth has been violated by the outside
world and that has to stop according to
them okay I know that there's a heat
wave in the in the southwest I saw that
the headline today on Drudge is that
California powers asking Californians
during the heat wave please turn off
your lights electricity are you living
by that no because I would die it's a
hundred nobody's living by that that's
why there's gonna be rolling brownouts
just like there are every single year
because we will not build any new
upgrades to the power grid or build any
new nuclear factories that will actually
create the power necessary for people in
Southern California to live decently
well then it's a good idea that you show
up on TV at let's say 5:50 in the
morning before the Sun comes out